so this is a really cool project that
you've been working on kind of Harkens
back to something that people love about
you the Sci-Fi so tell us all about
Savage Marines uh Salvage Marines is a
it was a book series by Sean Michael
Argo and so it's an IP that's already
out there and it's just uh it was a
thrill for me to be a part of it again
because it just you could tell from
reading the script and then the books
that this guy's a huge fan of Starship
Troopers so for me it was there's a
there's some Throwbacks to it and
there's some differences and it's just a
it's a darker vision of Starship
Troopers too in in a way and it's older
and and it's uh it was just a lot of fun
to do it I saw somebody put a picture up
of Casper Van Deen in a helmet from 1997
and Starship Troopers and then the
picture from this and like Johnny Rico
1997.
2022. what's this it's just which is
sweet so I love that enthusiasm that's a
it's infectious and makes you you know
just really appreciate getting to to do
what you love and being around people
you love and and this show was actually
most everybody in it was our were our
friends so we we really love each other
and get along so that's a lot of fun too
what was it like to strap on the helmet
and get the Blaster out and get back
into this world of sci-fi uh it was it
was surreal
um it was a surreal moment and I I've
really been wanting to do something like
that I've been wanting to do a Starship
Troopers TV series and then I got to do
this which was like doing it without
Starship Troopers but still doing it so
who is the character what's his
motivation what's he out there for so
Sam Heist the character I'm playing in
this one is uh everybody's born in in
this new dystopia this new world
everybody is you know born pretty much
with life debt and and then you you're
it's handed down to your children so
your debt kept more and more and more so
you're you're in a servitude to the
corporations one way to get out of it is
join the Salvage Marines Salvage Marines
80 mortality rate and then also the
wounding rate is like 98 so you're going
to lose an arm or leg you're going to
know but you could pay off your your
life debt if you do that but if you get
wounded and they have to put a new arm
on you then you're more in debt again so
it it it shows this this character At
first she joins up to to save his family
and then he starts realizing some of the
darkness behind it and Starship Troopers
my character was just like that's what
the mobile industry is good for and
that's what we do so I was straight
laceless my character in this starts
questioning some things which I love I
love doing both I'm not going to say
doing the Starship doing Starship was
amazing to have that and to be that
character and have people you know
really resonate and like it and love it
and and and it was really strict but
this character now uh he's older as I am
I'm old no no but
um in in it I uh we have a joke me and
Peter are talking one day and we down
the table all the young young Troopers
young Reapers is what they call them now
and uh
he goes okay let's just talk about the
elephant in the room we're old and goes
into and it's just so I love that we we
even deal with that in that and we did
we deal with ageism and we we do it in a
positive way so it was fun we're coming
up on 25th anniversary of Starship
Troopers Johnny Rico has become like a
staple for you know for sci-fi fans what
are some of the things people come up to
you and say like do they quote Lions
back to you they they come on do you
want to live forever come on here if you
want to live forever Rico's Roughnecks
and they they just they just start
yelling uh my kids grew up with me
getting yelled at and they just thought
that was normal so um people just
yelling at me somebody will be like what
are you doing what are you doing here
I'm like getting toilet paper
it happens
that's awesome so sci-fi has been a big
part of your life in your household are
you guys watching Sci-Fi movies sci-fi
shows I grew up on Star Trek I wanted to
be Captain Kirk because a lot of young
men and women wanted to
um so uh I was like oh my God I want to
be that and so when I get to do
something like this which is a throwback
Series this series is kind of like what
they probably would have been like for
stars for a Star Trek or Doctor Who or
Flash Gordon or anything like that
because we're nuts and bolts we were
just people out there really working it
we didn't have a big Studio behind us
luckily we have popcorn flicks that's
now
um uh loves it and behind it and they're
they're part of chicken soup of the soul
and crackle and they're they're they're
amazing and they love this and they
believe in it so they're they're putting
it out for free on popcornflix starting
July 28th for free I don't know how they
make money uh it's not my job but
they're they're they're uh they're doing
it for free so July 28th you can watch
it for free you can download this app
and you can watch it's not just my show
you can watch other movies and stuff
like that for free
I mean don't ask too many questions
right I don't I don't ask too many
questions because I don't know I'm not
good at answers
so your daughters are following your
footsteps as well getting into this old
business what are you guys working on
together my daughter uh well we've
worked on different things together but
we might be working on something again I
just gotta you know she it's so much fun
for me to see that she was you know she
plays Chrissy on uh stranger things and
so she's um she's like a a pop culture
moment right now and there's people that
are dressed up like her and cosplaying
her and I'm taking pictures and there's
people who are sending me pictures oh my
God I just ran into your daughter but
it's a cosplayer dressed up as like uh
and so so many people we were at the
airport and some girl comes and goes are
you the guy from Starship Troopers and
go yeah she goes what are you doing I'm
going oh I'm going here and she's like
and then my wife goes you know her his
because she had a stranger things shared
on she goes you know his sister's uh his
daughter is uh is Chrissy and she goes
I'm cosplaying Eddie and my girlfriend
is cosplaying uh Chrissy and so like I'm
like oh my God I mean she's like random
people like this just going so it's it's
all it's awesome do you so given that
did you get to know all these secrets
and twists and turns in advance and like
what was it like to sit on all those
Secrets without letting anybody know
about what was going on in the show so
my daughter had to sign an NDA
but I'm her dad
so I don't know if that really applies
so it was really nice to know and it's
hard not to say stuff so I was so
excited for it but to see it is one
thing it's it's a whole unique
experience and I was I was just really
grateful to watch her and she's I'm so
proud of her and I'm a lucky dad
um any tears when you saw her there for
the first time like what was that like
for you well I directed in a movie
called uh Sleeping Beauty for Asylum
like 15 years ago or whatever it was
um and she was she was amazing she
played Sleeping Beauty in it so and I
had Finn Jones and Olivia Dabo and uh it
was just uh it was a lot of fun to do
that and and uh I'm gonna do the Asylum
panel I guess tomorrow night but they
asked me to come back and do it just
because I got to direct that for them
they give me my first film to direct so
that was kind of fun I really always
appreciate those guys for that finally
we're here at Comic Con you've been
doing this since 97 right like what's it
like coming back here in 22 you know
after having all that experience with
the way it's changed and seeing fans
over the years so it's interesting
because I've been I've been thinking
about that a lot because I came here in
1997 when I could drive right up to the
the convention center and park outside
and walk in and I didn't need to pass
they're like oh my God if you're here
well yeah we'll get you in we'll try to
get your pass away you know they were so
excited and so then I've been here for
Tarzan and for Sleepy Hollow Mortal
Kombat uh and and con man series with
Alan Alan Turek and Nathan villian uh
you know so I've been I've been doing it
all and it was great and got really
crazy and crazy and then I come back two
years of not doing it and we're finally
back and it's like coming home
yeah and you know what's interesting is
it's not as big as it was
uh I mean it's not as crowded as it was
it's still big
um but it's not as crowded as it was
just before the pandemic so well dude
salvation means super cool uh
congratulations on everything and we're
I mean super excited for the 25th
anniversary Starship Troopers any big
plans uh well we did a we did a panel
and I think they're going to put it part
of a new DVD release thing so we did a
panel with a whole bunch of us so it was
a lot of fun awesome thanks buddy